you are the CEO of Boston Dynamics uh
what's it take to be SEO of a robotics
company she started as a humble engineer
uh PhD
um just looking at your journey
what does it take to go from being
from building the thing
to Leading a company what are some of
the big challenges for you
uh courage I would I would put front and
center for multiple reasons
I talked earlier about the courage to
tackle hard problems
so I think there's courage required not
just of me but of of all of the people
who work at Boston Dynamics
I also think we have a lot of really
smart people we have people who are way
smarter than I am
and I it takes a kind of courage to be
willing to lead them and to trust that
you have something to offer to somebody
who probably is maybe a better engineer
than I am
um
adaptability you know part of the it's
been a great career for me I never would
have guessed I'd stayed in one place for
30 years
um and the job has always changed
um I didn't I didn't really aspire to be
CEO from the very beginning but it was
the natural progression of things there
was always a there always needed to be
some level of management that was needed
and so
you know when I saw
something that needed to be done that
wasn't being done I just stepped in to
go do it and oftentimes because we were
full of such uh strong Engineers
oftentimes that was in the management
direction or it was in the business
development direction or or
organizational hiring geez I was not I
was the main person hiring at Boston
Dynamics for probably 20 years so I was
the head of HR basically so I you know
just willingness to sort of tackle any
piece of the business that that needs it
and then and be willing to shift is
there something you could say to what it
takes to hire a great team what uh
what's a good interview process how do
you know uh the guy or Gallery are going
to make a great member of uh of a
engineering team that's doing some of
the hardest work in the world
you know we developed an interview
process that I was quite fond of it's a
little bit of a hard interview process
because the best interviews you ask
somebody about what they're interested
in and what they're good at
and if if they can describe to you
something that they worked on and you
saw they really did the work they solved
the problems
and you saw their passion for it
um and you could ask but but what makes
that hard is you have to ask a probing
question about it you have to be smart
enough about what they're telling you
their expert at to ask a good question
and so it takes a pretty talented team
to do that
but if you can do that that's how you
tap into ah this person cares about
their work they really did the work
they're excited about it that's the kind
of person I want at my company
you know at Google they taught us about
their interview process
and it was a little bit different
um you know
we we evolved the process at Boston
Dynamics where it didn't matter if you
were an engineer or you were an uh
administrative assistant or a financial
person or a technician
you gave us a presentation you came in
and you gave us a presentation you had
to stand up and talk in front of us
and I just thought that was great to tap
into those things I didn't subscribed to
you at Google they taught us and I think
I understand why you're right they're
hiring tens of thousands of people they
need a more standardized process so they
would sort of err on the other side
where they would ask you a standard
question I'm going to ask you a
programming question and I'm just going
to ask you to write code in front of me
that's a terrifying you know application
process yeah it does let you compare
candidates really well but it doesn't
necessarily let you tap in to who they
are right because you're asking them to
answer your question instead of you
asking them about what they're
interested in
um but frankly that process is hard to
scale and even at Boston Dynamics
we're not doing that with everybody
anymore we're but we are still doing
that with you know the technical people
but we've because we too now need to
sort of increase our rate of hiring uh
not everybody's giving a presentation
anymore but you're still ultimately
trying to find that uh basic seed of
passion yeah into the world you know did
they really do it did they did they find
something interesting or curious you
know and do they care about it I think
uh somebody admires
um Jim Keller and he he likes details
so one of the ways you could if you get
a person to talk about what they're
interested in how many details like how
much of the Whiteboard can you fill out
yeah well I think you figure out did
they really do the work if they know
some of the details yes and if they have
to wash over the details well then they
didn't do it because special engineering
the work is in the details yeah